[Music]
morning John it's Wednesday February
28th and it's story day our story today
is called everyone poops in my pants by
Hank green my name is Hank and I have a
small problem everyone poops in my pants
each morning I wake up and dozens of
people surround my house chanting what
do we want to poop in Hanks pants when
do we want to poop in them now hey hey
ho ho into heck's pants we gotta go hey
hey ho ho into Hank's pants we gotta go
poop now I know what you were thinking
you're thinking Hank I believe that many
people have pooped in your pants but I
remain unconvinced it everyone has
pooped in your pants and that is true
enough for instance many poor people
haven't pooped in my pants because they
lack the resources to fly to Montana and
many babies haven't pooped in my pants
because they're too busy pooping in
their own I'm just saying that
statistically an improbably large number
of people have pooped in my pants my mom
and dad and my brother John have all
pooped in my pants kirsten dunst was
wearing and pooping in my pants during
the entire filming of spider-man 2 the
entire Liverpool Football Club pooped in
my home Bros immediately after winning
the 2005 UEFA Cup German novelist Gunter
Grass pooped in my pants while wearing
his Nobel Prize Stephen Dedalus is just
one of the many fictional characters who
have non-fictional 'i pooped in my
non-fictional pants Al Roker had my
pants tailored to fit him and then
pooped in them Vladimir Ilich Lenin died
in 1924 but has nonetheless pooped in my
pants George W Bush is so incompetent
that he failed to poop in my pants
although he did poop near my pants and
then later claimed that he had never
intended to poop in my pants and that no
one in his
ministration had ever talked about
pooping in anyone's pants having seen
his poop I can report that it looks
exactly like [ __ ] wow those guys
must be selling the president's war plan
people often ask me Hank does it bother
you that everyone poops in your pants
yes it does sometimes something great
will happen
like the other day Barack Obama came by
and he pooped in my pants and his poop
kind of makes me believe in America
again but mostly I just like having
people poop in my pants but everyone has
a cross to bear
some people have chronic back pain some
people are on Team Karen some people are
Republicans me I just happen to have
pants into which people really like to
poop it could certainly be worse it's
like Monty Python member Eric Idle once
told me while he was pooping in my pants
why is Luke on the fly all I know blood
[Music]